>> Laura: THE PARENT COMPANY OF
THE MANDALAY BAY HOTEL IN VEGAS
RELEASED THE VIDEO OF STEVEN
PADDOCK IN THE DAYS BEFORE THE
DEADLIEST MASS SHOOTING IN U.S.
HIS FRIDAY.
THEY SHOW HIM STANDING CLOSE TO
THE BELLHOP AS THEY DELIVERED
NUMEROUS BAGS FULL OF WHAT WE
KNOW NOW, WEAPONS AND
AMMUNITION.
AS THE PRIME SUSPECT IN THE
OCTOBER SHOOTING, PADDOCK'S
MOTIVE REMAINS A MYSTERY AS HE
APPARENTLY KILLED HIMSELF RATHER
THAN CAPTURED.
LET'S ASK THE EXPERTS WHAT THE
VIDEOS MIGHT REVEAL.
RANDY SUTTON, RETIRED LAS VEGAS
POLICE OFFICER.
AARON COHEN IS A SECURITY AND
COUNTER TERROR SPECIALIST.
GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
RANDY, LET'S START WITH YOU.
I WANT TO GO PIECE BY PIECE IF
WE CAN THROUGH THE VIDEO.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO GET SPECIFIC, AND
ADVANCE THE ANALYSIS AS WE DO
IT.
FIRST WE'RE WATCHING STEPHEN
PADDOCK CHECKING IN, THE VIDEO
WE'VE BEEN CALLING FOR FOR
MONTHS AT THE MANDALAY FRONT
DESK.
LET'S WATCH IT.
YOU CAN SEE HIM CHECKING IN.
YOU GUYS HAVE BOTH WATCHED IT.
WHAT SHOULD WE BE LOOKING FOR?
>> WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS, HE'S A
HIGH ROLLER.
HE'S A HEAVY GAMBLER.
HE'S CHECKING IN AT THE V.I.P.
DESK, WHICH IS AFFORDING HIM --
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO STAND IN LINE
LIKE OTHER PEOPLE, IT'S
EXPEDITED PROCESS.
THEY KNOW HIM VERY WELL, HE'S
JUST PUTTING HIS NAME IN THERE,
GETTING ALL OF THE CREDIT CARD
STUFF SITUATED.
AND HE'S ON HIS WAY.
>> Laura: LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT PIECE OF VIDEO.
THIS IS WITH THE BELL BOY, ALL
OF THE LUGGAGE.
BIG BAG.
AND HE'S BENDING OVER TO FIX HIS
PANTS.
WHY IS THAT IN ANY WAY RELEVANT?
>> WELL, HE TAKES THE BACK
ENTRANCE WHICH THE HOTEL CLAIMS
IS NOT UNCOMMON.
TAKING A SERVICE ELEVATOR.
I'VE NEVER BROUGHT BAGS INTO A
HOTEL IN VEGAS AND GONE THROUGH
THE SERVICE ELEVATOR.
THAT'S AN ADVANTAGE.
PARDON ME WHILE I LOOK AT THE
FOOTAGE AND I'M SMANING, SECOND
LONG DELAY.
HIS BODY LANGUAGE, HANDS IN HIS
POCKET, LEGS ARE CROSSED, HE'S
TRYING TO BLOCK OUT ANY
NERVOUSNESS.
HE HAS ONE HAND UP, RIGHT NOW.
HE'S IN, IT JUST LOOKS LIKE HE'S
GENERALLY UNCOMFORTABLE.
FIDGETING WITH HIS FACE,
TOUCHING HIS FACE, THAT'S NOT
UNCOMMON WITH THE BEHAVIORAL RED
FLAG SOMEBODY TRYING TO COVER
SOMETHING.
AGAIN, HE'S SCRATCHING HIS HEAD,
AS I LOOK AT THE FOOTAGE.
ALL OF THESE, THIS IS NONVERBAL
COMMUNICATING WHICH IS WHAT I'M
TRAINED IN, SPECIFICALLY, IN
ISRAEL FOR BOARDING FLIGHTS IN
ISRAEL, TO GO TO ISRAEL.
THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR, YOU CAN'T
LIE WITH NONVERBAL
COMMUNICATING.
SOMEBODY IS COVERING INTENSELY,
HE'S FIDGETING, SHUFFLING, LET'S
GETTED CART MOVING,
UNCOMFORTABLE, THE SHIRT IS
UNTUCKED, COULD BE A WEAPON ON
HIS WAIST.
>> Laura: THE TIME LINE THAT IS
APPARENTLY NOT AGREED TO,
THERE'S NO TIME LINE THAT ALL
AUTHORITIES SEEM TO SAY YES THIS
IS HOW IT HAPPENED.
THIS THERE'S A LOT OF SWIRLING
CONSPIRACY THEY ARIES ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
THE GUY WAS NOT HE WAS KNOWN BY
AUTHORITIES, WE THOUGHT HE WAD A
CRIMINAL HISTORY BUT THERE
WASN'T A CRIMINAL HISTORY.
>> THERE'S A LOT AT PLAY HERE.
WHAT WE SAW TODAY, IS VERY
INTERESTING IN A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT WAYS, LAURA.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT WE
HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE ACCESS TO
SEE HIM ENGAGED IN HIS DAILY
ACTIVITIES WHILE HE WAS STAYING
AT THE HOTEL.
YOU HAVE TO ASK WHAT IS THE
TIMING, WHY IS THIS HAPPENING
NOW?
IT'S INTERESTING THAT THE HOTEL
FINALLY DECIDED TO GIVE UP THIS
FOOTAGE TO A MAJOR NEWS SOURCE.
WHAT'S THE REASON FOR THAT, IS
IT BECAUSE THERE IS SO MUCH IN
PLAY HERE, WITH PEOPLE, YOU
KNOW, ESPOUSING CONSPIRACY THEY
ARIES F YOU LOOK AT THIS,
THERE'S FINALLY SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY, BEING
INTERESTED IN THE SUBJECT,
FINALLY GETTING TO SEE SOMETHING
HERE.
>> Laura: ARE WE SEEING
SOMETHING, AARON, THAT TOS US,
THE KIND OF GUY HE IS?
OR MOTIVATION?
WE'RE NOT GETTING TO ANY OF
THAT.
HE'S A GUY WHO SAT IN FRONT OF A
SLOT MACHINE FOR HOURS AND HOURS
AND HOURS.
BROUGHT THE HEAVY BAGS IN,
SERVICE ELEVATOR, V.I.P.
CHECK-IN, SWAYING BACK AND
FORTH, THE EXTRA VIDEO HERE,
WHERE WE SEE HIM SWAYING BACK
AND FORTH WITH THE BELL BOY AS
WELL.
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO SEE HIM
THERE.
THERE IT IS.
BUT, STILL, WE KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT THIS GUY.
THE BIGGEST MASS SHOOTING IN
U.S. HISTORY AND WE KNOW STILL
VERY, VERY LITTLE ABOUT HIM.
AARON?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S WHY I'M JUMPING ALL OVER.
LOOK AT HIM, HE HAS THE HANDS IN
HIS POCKETS, AWKWARD SHUFFLE,
HE'S NERVOUS, PROJECTING
NERVOUSNESS, HE'S FLAGGING LIKE
CRAZY.
THESE ARE THE RED FLAGS THAT WE
LOOK FOR, AGAIN, IN ISRAEL, THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HOW WE DO
SECURITY AND HOW THE REST OF THE
WORLD DOES SECURITY, WE KNOW
THAT YOU CAN SPOT THE BEHAVIOR
OF A MURDERER BEFORE HE COMMITS
THE ACT OF MURDER.
JUST HIS RED FLAG.
HE'S FLAGGING LIKE CRAZY.
NOT MANDALAY BAY'S FAULT.
NO ONE IS TRAINED TO DO THIS.
EXCEPT FOR CERTAIN ASPECTS OF
THE FBI FOR THEIR PROFILING.
CERTAIN PORTIONS OF BORTDER
PATROL GETTING BETTER.
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS GUY.
IT'S A COMPLETE MYSTERY.
I UNDERSTAND ALL.
CONSPIRACY.
TO GO TO RANDY'S PIECE, I HAVE
KNOWN RANDY FOR A WHILE, HE'S
VERY, VERY SMART AND KNOWS VEGAS
BETTER THAN ANYBODY, HOW HOTELS
ARE.
BE ON VOULGSLY THE HOTEL PUT OUT
THE VIDEO TO COVER THEIR BUTTS.
THEY WANT TO GET IT OUT THERE,
LOOK, WE CAN'T -- THE HOTEL IS
BASICALLY, TO ME, SAYING, GUYS,
YOU LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE HERE,
YOU LOOK AT THIS GUY, AND YOU
CAN SEE JUST AS WE CAN, THAT
HE'S JUST A NORMAL GUY, HE'S
GAMBLING, CHECKING IN.
BUT ONCE YOU START CRACKING THIS
THING OPEN, IT'S, LAURA, HOW DO
WE USE THIS VIDEO.
>> Laura: TO PREVENT THE NEXT
TIME.
>> PREVENT IT FROM HAPPENING.
>> 20 BAGS?
THAT'S CRAZY.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE PATHOLOGY THAT
HASN'T BEEN ADDRESSED, THE
PATHOLOGY OF THE HEAVY GAMBLER,
SOME ONE THAT CAN SPEND EIGHT
HOURS AT A TIME, LITERALLY,
SPENDING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS AT A SITTING, HOW DO
YOU THINK THAT PLAYS INTO THE
FACTORS HERE?
I THINK THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
HERE THAT'S BEING MISSED.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK IS BEING
MISSED?
THAT'S MY ISRAELI ANSWER, WHERE
YOU GOING?
>> I THINK THAT THE PATHOLOGY OF
THE DEGENERATE GAMBLER, PLAY AS
ROLE IN THE WAY WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT THIS MAN AS SUSPECT.
>> IT'S ISOLATED, SITS IN FRONT
OF THE MACHINE, YOU SKO SAY THAT
ABOUT A LOT OF PEOPLE.
NOT EVERYBODY THAT SITS IN FRONT
OF A MACHINE, BLUE HAIRED PEOPLE
ALL OVER REGULAR AS SITTING IN
FRONT OF MACHINES.
>> WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO IS THE
TOOLS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DEVELOPED TO BE ABLE TO PREDICT
VIOLENCE.
YOU LOOK AT BEHAVIOR.
THE QUESTION IS WHEN ARE WE
WORKS AND HOW DO WE DISPERSE TO
IT THE MEGAHOTELS AND CASINOS,
AND ALL OF THE OTHER
MEGAINFRASTRUCTURE PLACES, LIKE
THE MASSIVE MALL IN MINNESOTA.
>> Laura: ABSOLUTELY.
>> AND LOOK AND CREATE
BEHAVIORAL DETECTION PROGRAMS.
YOU CAN'T THROW MORE SECURITY
GUARDS AT THIS PROBLEM.
YOU HAVE TO TRAIN THE GUARDS.
AS SOON AS WE START TAKING THE
PROFESSION MORE SERIOUSLY, THEN
I THINK WE'LL START HAVING A
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION.
>> Laura: IT TAKES MONEY,
TRAINING, AND YOU CAN'T BE
POLITICALLY CORRECT.
WE'RE ALL POLITICALLY CORRECT.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
I WANT TO HAVE YOU BOTH ON